les familles grecques traditionnels on
peut toujours voir l'espagne hôpital ça
fait partie d'un autre répertoire
culinaire habituellement en forme de
triangle se fait partir de presque
toutes nos occasions infesté le mot grec
ce pas la copie ta signifie tout
simplement tarte aux épinards à la base
ça devait contenir de l'épinard de
l'épinard un peu de retard
des jeux qui évidemment un peu du beurre
pour apprêter à matelas
aujourd'hui j'ai opté pour des
ingrédients vraiment de base auquel à
chaque personne chaque famille pourrait
ajouter d'autres fromages des échalotes
des oignons du passif de la nef et
d'autres épices vingt cinq minutes plus
tard voici ce que ça donne
[Musique]
facile à préparer à la maison on trouve
une grande variété de ces bouchers dans
les rayons des surgelés en épicerie il
ya l'usure compagnie qu'ils ont il ya
bien capturé je produis là dans sa forme
vraiment traditionnels alors vous voyez
il ya comme une panoplie des choix avec
l'aide anastasia nous avons évalué une
quinzaine de produits en termes de côté
nutritionnel
je peux vous dire que celui là d' aider
et stable un choix de président puisque
d'art se trouve à être parmi les
meilleurs choix accompagné de pillaro en
spirale et alpha en mini rouleau pour
leurs présentations différentes nous les
soumettons à l'aveuglent au pape et
experte de deux familles grecques
le chef du restaurant ikanos constant
menzah et sa mère nicole ainsi que
l'importateur de vins grecs crise des
dettes et sa fille evangeline à présent
partagés être ensemble en famille
historiquement il faisait les moutons
dans les montagnes se faisait des petits
tapis parce qu'on est supposé avoir dans
un sauna kopitar pour moi c'est le fatah
pilane est maghrébin ne faisait pas
juste aux iep noël faisait avec plein de
sauvages qu'elle allait ramasser une
petite amertume
personnellement ça manque souvent à
ispagnac hôpital commercial lé petit
côté un peu d'amertume c'est souvent un
peu trop sucré personnellement c'est la
compare le terrain j'ai mis 20 minutes
parce que mon ami son minute franck et
se ferme
[Musique]
premier constat à la sortie du four two
l'espada kopitar manque de cuisson
permet à notre humble avis c'est pas ces
cuistres est plus mou fait qu'on voudra
mais trophos confrères la maison parce
que je trouve qu'on ne la rend pas
service de les servir et un différend
sur la faune doit-on fourmont fauqué 2
nuls 3 précision miba sédhiou
[Musique]
alors c'est l'heure de la petite bouchée
c'est bon ça goûte les épisodes la peau
d'âne elles sont aussi très grand salut
est un peu la patte pas cuites comme on
peut voir les 6 passes et cuire 1 en
trois matches depuis son casque les
filons sont vraiment calé ensemble my
home ne coûte pas produit dans chaque
bougie blanche non de vous passer des
fois elles rendront à mon âge des petits
oignons les aides en union de fait à les
avalanches et ajuste de répit nantes il
a pas pire une autre
ça il ya beaucoup de parts alors il faut
pour manger un peu plus pour saluer le
beau bien plus de la plus savoureuse
somme il a tout même salué ici je sais
les chrétiens quand on vérifie la fiche
nutritionnelle habituellement ça dépasse
les 15% en sodium dieu au fromage
notamment la fête à hockey qui est quand
même qui se trouve être une fromage salé
quand on fait la spa de capital chez
nous on peut aussi opter pour des faits
tels qu'ils sont - sané et donc diminuer
la part de celles la plupart des
produits sont également assez riche en
gras saturés
vérifiez bien car certaines contiennent
près de cinq fois plus que d'autres la
liste d'ingrédients est souvent longue
et nous avons retrouvé de l'huile de
palme dans la majorité des produits non
c'est pas un mauvais produit comme tout
produit qu'on trouve dans le marché
c'est tout en modération
c'est sûr que c'est pas des aliments
qu'on veut consommer à chaque jour en
grande quantité
ces femmes formant de celui là mouais
moi je sais pas la première manche est
une farce d'autres choisissaient chez
100% pas trop et c'est par six seulement
au milieu là nos goûteurs ont par contre
eu un coup de coeur pour les hispaniques
hôpital choix du président taton ont
pensé qu'ils étaient plus de face à la
france au plus de profondeur des goûts
de clairement plus de fait c'est plus
complets ainsi à plus de faire ce que
les autres qu'il a passé un goût un peu
plus prononcée loyers plus de détails
il ya clairement de l'aneth c'est un
puzzle
l'autre plongeur des saveurs
traditionnelles équilibré et gilles
simon se produit donc une des bonnes
options lors de vos réceptions un défaut
bien sûr d'avoir un chef grec pour vous
en cuisine et voilà
sa traque bourse que c'est supposé
d'habitants qui part avec les
personnages s'étonnera pas complète
les protéines sannois les oignons guzzo
nyon la neige nous quand on marche on
marche dessus je m'en souviens donc
parce que j'aime trop ça